hello everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
today we will take you through the top
mongodb and react js full course we will
see the various database operations and
react components that will increase your
in hand knowledge of mongodb and
react.js
mongodb is a nosql document based
database management system
and react is a front-end javascript
library
it is an open source and a leading web
application framework of javascript
by the end of this full course i can
assure you that you will have a brief
knowledge of mongodb and react.js
but before we begin let me tell you that
we have regular updates on multiple tech
videos
so if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss any update from simply learn
so without further delay let's get
started
let's go through the agenda for this
full course
first we'll see what is mongodb
after that we'll see how to install
mongodb on windows machine moving ahead
we'll see different curved operations
performed on mongodb
moving ahead we'll see how to connect
mongodb with python
then we'll start the react component
we'll see what is react.js after that
we'll see advantages and disadvantages
of react.js
we'll see features of react.js
components of react.js
react props and state
then we'll see how to connect react.js
with node.js and some projects of react
so let's begin so what exactly is
mongodb
it is a document oriented nosql database
it was initially released in august 27
2009
mongodb replaces the concept of rows of
conventional relational data models with
something called documents
it offers developers the flexibility to
work with evolving data models since
it's document based mongodb allows
embedded documents arrays and represents
complex hierarchical relationships using
a single record it is also schema free
which means that the keys defined in the
document are not fixed
as a result massive data migrations can
be ruled out
but you must be wondering when there's
something like sql why is nosql or
mongodb used
there are a few reasons why mongodb is
widely used
first up is flexibility
mongodb's notion of documents that can
contain sub-documents nested in complex
hierarchies is really expressive and
flexible
flexible query model a user can
selectively index some part of a
document or a query based on attribute
values regular expressions or ranges
next up is native aggregation
native aggregation allows its users to
extract and transform data from mongodb
and either load them in a new format or
export it from mongodb to other data
sources it makes it extremely compatible
lastly as mentioned earlier the schema
free model now applications get the
power and responsibility to interpret
different properties in different ways
now that you know what mongodb is and
why exactly it's used let's have a look
at the characteristics of mongodb
firstly it's a general purpose database
now mongodb can serve heterogeneous
loads and multiple purposes within an
application
again it has a flexible schema design
document oriented approaches with
non-defined attributes that can be
modified on the fly is a key contrast
between mongodb and any other relational
database
next up is scalability and load
balancing it's built to scale both
vertically but most importantly
horizontally using sharding and
architect can share load between
different instances and achieve both
read and write scalability
when it comes to load balancing this
happens automatically and transparently
to the user by the shard
balancer again we have aggregation
framework now mongodb offers an extract
transform and load framework that
eliminates the need for complex data
pipelines
native replication now data will get
replicated
across a replica set without complicated
setup
security features both authentication
and authorization are taken into account
in mongodb
next up is json now json is widely used
across the web for front-end and api
communication and as such it's easier
when the database is also compatible
with the same protocol
lastly we have mapreduce now again
mapreduce is an excellent tool to build
data pipelines and mongodb uses
mapreduce readily now let's quickly have
a look at the working of mongodb
data is stored in documents with the
help of key value pairs
now the data is stored in the bs1 format
at the back end mongodb converts json
data into a binary format known as bson
mongodb also makes provision for nested
data now all of these documents are
stored in a collection
these collections hold multiple
documents and since mongodb is
schema-less the documents in one
collection need not be similar now again
these collections are stored in the
entire mongodb database as mentioned
earlier mongodb makes provision for
nested data this makes fetching of data
extremely efficient when compared to
other databases now you must be
wondering where exactly mongodb can be
applied or used so let me help you with
that several areas of technologies use
mongodb as their dbms currently some of
them are internet of things mobile
applications real-time analysis
personalization
catalog management and content
management
now all said and done let's look at some
of the companies that use mongodb
currently
companies like toyota sap astrazeneca
adobe verizon cisco barclays and google
among others readily deploy mongodb as
their database management system in this
video i'm gonna help you install and set
up mongodb on your windows system
you will have to navigate to the
official mongodb website
and here
you can see
software
so go ahead and click on community
server under software
and
you can see that the current version is
4.4.4
and the platform is windows and make
sure that the package is msi all right
now go ahead and
press download
so this could take a while
all right so once it's downloaded
go ahead and install it
now since it's already installed on my
system uh the installation process will
be different but you just need to follow
the steps there and finally install it
so once you're done with the
installation you can go to your c drive
and here you can click on program files
and you can see that mongodb is
installed
and inside of it you have the server
folder and then you have the 4.4 folder
and then you have the bin folder right
so here you have the application that is
your [ __ ] and the mongod applications
both are executable files now the mongod
file or the application is the daemon
process now this is the background
process that make sure you retrieve the
data from the database access the data
so it does all the background tasks so
after the installation now you need to
create a path to this file by doing this
you don't have to always go to the bin
folder and then execute the file you can
directly execute the file on your
command prompt right so for that let's
just
go to our environment variables
but before that let's just uh
copy this path
right
and here under the user variable section
click on path
and say edit
and go ahead and just paste it right
i've already pasted mine so just go
ahead and paste it and click on ok
and
say okay
right so now you've created the path
successfully now let's head to our
command prompt and run the [ __ ] file
so
here you can just directly type [ __ ]
since the path has already been created
so just go ahead and say [ __ ]
[Music]
and here you can see
that your
[ __ ] server has been generated
and with this you know that your in
mongodb has been successfully installed
and your server is up and running right
so just for confirmation let's see if
there are any databases and how much
space they've occupied so you can right
now just type
show
dbs
and when you click on it it says admin
config and localhost and all of it is
zero
so with that you have successfully
installed mongodb on your system and
it's up and running
all right in this particular tutorial we
will be learning what mongodb is all
about and their advantages and some
practical demonstrations so let's get
started now
so here in mumbo db we would like to
discuss about what is a mobile db so as
we know the mongodb is known to be
called a traditional
document based database
okay which stores the data in a document
okay nosql means
it doesn't says like no to sql
instead it says not only sql that means
it is not only sql but it is supporting
the other approaches too
okay so the document based when you talk
about it actually represents the typical
hierarchical relationship using the
single records
that means how the records are related
with each other so that's how exactly it
represents
and it is a pure schema free environment
so that you really do not need to have
a schema before you go and develop this
program so it is a pure schema less
environment
due to that it is giving you far more
better flexibility when you talk about
completely unorganized involvement
so what is nosql so the here's the idea
about a nosql so it is completely into
the non-relational database like
traditionally if you see
any non-relational database
uh you talk about
uh typical nosql
uh
it's purely into the document base here
nosql does not use any tables like in
rows and columns
a traditional idb base approach if you
see there they are using a complete
table structure like they talk about
columns they talk about rows and are all
about
so here
in nosql it stores the relationship data
in the documents
so the different type of nosql databases
are available like you talk about called
document based you talk about key value
base you talk about white column based
and graph based
different options are available for the
nosql but the one which we are using it
mongodb it is a purely document based
database
now here we would like to go ahead with
some demonstrations like talking about
like how mobo db installation works and
the other aspects
okay everyone so now we're gonna start
working on
the first option called mongodb
installation
[Music]
okay
see mongodb installation is very simple
if you open a website and go for
this website name called
mongodb
download
if you talk about mobile db download
you're gonna see
the official website called mongodb
community download is available
when you click here
so you can see it is taking the current
version to 4.4.6
mac os it by default detected my
platform however you can select
depends on which platform you have it
and after that you will be clicking on
this download
okay so it'll get ready for if you're
from windows
i would say
in this windows
you can
select
appropriate option like two options are
available you can talk about msi or talk
about zip
my recommendation is you can stick to
the zip powered portion because it won't
start any mobo dv services behind the
scene
that is really helpful because you
really do not want to motivate you to be
there running unnecessary even if it is
not required my suggestion is to stick
to the zip file so
here once the mongodb is there so you
will be seeing that two files available
inside the mongodb folder inside the bin
so once you download the zip you will
find two different type of files are
available let me mention those
so
inside the bin folder
you will see two files one is called
mongodb
okay another file which is available
called mobo
mobo t is to basically start a mongod
server
and the mongodb is actually the client
which will connect with the mongodb
clear so if you are in
windows environment so once you are
inside this bin folder of your
zip file
you will get the mongodb so you have to
double click on this it'll start a new
command prompt
so you do not need to do anything
further just minimize this command
prompt and go inside the bin folder
again and click on the
another binary file called mobile so it
will get start as a client
okay since i'm using the macbook here
the concept is little
different about how mongodb can be used
okay so this is just a basic way of how
the moon is being used into your code
okay everyone so now
as we are in the
macbook so here to start mongodb we have
a very special way to start with so here
i'll start with my terminal
and here i would like to paste one very
simple command to start my mongodb
database that is called mongodb
and after that you have to say hyphen
iphone db path it is the place where
your database will be starting and one
more important thing i forgot to mention
like
mongodb would not start automatically
inside your
windows machine unless
inside your c drive you have to create a
new folder name called data and under
this you have to create a new folder
name called db
because automatically when the mongod
starts it looks inside the c drive data
inside a db folder there your all
records will get stored so do not forget
whenever you're trying to use the
mongodb so you must make have you must
have this particular
folder structure in place in your local
machine otherwise this is not going to
start
every time you start your mongodb
without this
location it automatically terminates so
to avoid those make sure that you have
this data db folder ready with you
however you could also change the
location of this particular folder
structure for which we will discuss it
little later on but as of now
we can see i'm giving my
location that is called iphone 7 db path
slash data
i hit enter you can see now my mobile db
is starting now
and since it's stuck so i have to start
the new terminal now
so here
i open the another tab
and type [ __ ]
and the moment i type mobile now you can
see it is now connected with my mongodb
and now it is ready
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay
now
to check
which other databases are available to
you so you can just type show
dbs
so it will show you the number of
databases which are already there
inside your existing
newly installed mongodb
but you can go back and create
new database too here you can see some
databases are already present however
you go back and create the new databases
into your system
and to create this database
we have very simple option available
here
name call
use
simply db
if i say use simplydb it automatically
creates this database and take you
inside
let's see now you can see you say use
simplydb it automatically creates though
it is not there but automatically takes
you in while creating those
okay so that means you are in current
database name called simplydb
so if you are not sure which database
you are in so you can just type dbs
or db
and it will show you that your current
database is simply db
that's it so your database is set
and we are all good to go ahead with our
next level development
hello everybody and welcome back
in a previous video you have seen like
how to create a database and
how to identify whether my database is
there or not so if you remember
previously we have created our database
using use keyword so if i just see my
databases which we have created is last
time so how we can check this out we can
say
show
space dbs
okay so you can see we have a got
database
list but we do not have any database
which we have created last time is
registered here that's quite surprising
because when we have created our
database it should be listed here but it
is not let's do one more time i'm saying
use
sn db
and
i'm saying switch to sldb
now when i say once again show dbs
so i still don't see my databases listed
here there is a reason the reason is
according to the mongodb rule unless we
have minimum one record or collection is
stored inside my mongodb it really can't
show in the list now i want to tell you
about a few important things
now
here when we talk about called mongodb
in this mongodb
compared to the relational database
here the table which is actually an idb
message is called here it is called
collection okay
db
is still called
db here
okay that means the database will be
still called database
but
row
what you use this word in a traditional
rdbms here it is known as called
document
if you remember i told you like it is a
document based database so here every
single record what you try to insert it
is not called
a typical row it is instead called a
document so every table is called
collection and every single row it is
called
document
that's what exactly the difference is
okay
now here once it is ready we will go
ahead and talk about our next feature
now
well
we have to basically go and create a new
collection
okay so what you can say db
dot
create
collection and here i can pass my
collection name i can say
demo
collection
so once it is done
i can see it is collection is created
in typical language i can say
the table is created and now when i try
to see same show dbs
i can see my
database is now listed
okay that's how exactly it works so the
very simplest way of how we use in my
code
well in our previous examples we have
seen like how we can create a collection
and we can give the name and i can see
the details are listed
when i say show dbs but there's a
another alternative option available
where you can just do that without even
saying db.create collection
well
if i want to create a collection i
really don't need this particular
functionality called create collection i
can directly use this statement name
called
db
dot
db dot sl
student
dot
insert
and here
we would like to add the property like a
name
and here we can say
admin
now what is that meaning is when you say
db dot sl student dot insert
and i hit enter you can see the
uninserted one
and surprisingly when you try to say
press enter
you will see this sl student
is not a collection which we have
created earlier
so what this line does this line
not only create the collection for you
but also add a record inside with this
property called name because that is a
mongodb and mongodb is always following
the json based structure and due to that
it goes with the key and value appears
so db is a predefined keyword sm student
is a collection name insert is a command
through which you are trying to insert
the record
now to check how many collections are
there
okay so we have one
property call show
show collections
when i say show collections i can list
down those number of
collections or else i can set tables in
a typical rdbms language
which are there added in my system
so essence student in which i can see
the record is inserted so if i want to
confirm i can simply say
db dot
sl
student dot find find is a function
through which i can list out those
number of records which are added i say
fine and you can see that the records
are
received at the same time when i say db
dot the name call demo collection
okay db.democollection.find
i'll find no record reason because this
collection was created but there was no
record which was inserted in
but you will see when i
write this command called sl student dot
insert it not only create a new
collection for me but also
insert the record into my
table also called a collection
that's where exactly it is giving you
the advantage when you want the
collections to be created along with the
data this is the way how you can really
do this
clear
but
whenever you talk about
db.create collection many people always
think about what is the significance of
having this db.create collection
look
db.createcollection is having its own
significance we never recommend
this technique
okay to create a collection because when
you create a collection you always
bring
some restrictions
some terminology which missed out
whenever you talk about this line
so having this db.create collection you
can also offer some
additional capping which is not possible
when you use tbi.org
collection in what is insert so you
might be thinking what those cappings
you're talking about let me try to brief
you
when i say db
dot
create
collection and here we are providing the
first name called support student
okay when i say student
so after this student additional
parameters what we can pass is this when
i say
capped
colon
true
what are we saying cap colon true so you
are enabling the capping
after that the next parameter i'm going
to pass that is normal is called size
in this size we are providing the size
suppose i am saying
5 2
4
and also we are saying 2 double 8 0 that
is the size of 5 mb and here we are
giving call max
colon
5.
what exactly that meaning is see the
meaning is very simple whenever you try
to bring this create collection option
so capping true means you are enabling
the capping so what is that meaning is
it is trying to say
in this particular collection name
called student
maximum number of
documents
can be either 5
or less than 5.
clear and the collective size of
documents cannot be increased to more
than 5 mb
that means you're trying to say
either
by adding the total number of five
records the collective size of five
document will reach to 5 mb
okay or else the maximum number of five
documents can be
stored so whichever fills earlier you
may have a total number of four
documents which are pretty heavy and
they
reach to the size 5mb and beyond that
the next document won't be added or else
you can have the five documents which
has not yet even reached so any option
will help you to achieve this
so that's where exactly you can offer
the capping but this is only possible
when the user is trying to
say
db.createcollection this option is not
possible when you're trying to use this
so that's the benefit of having this
db.create collection and this is what we
always recommend
well
now we would like to talk about our next
feature here
inside the same
mongodb so we now know how to create a
collection how to create a database and
how to switch from one database to
another database
now we will tell you like how to insert
a document so far we have already seen
how to insert a document inside a
mongodb now we would like to also show
you how we can insert the documents
using multiple techniques
so remember one thing
tv comes with two different type of
documents
one is called
relational document and second is called
embedded document
mostly while working with mongodb we
always recommend you to use
embedded documents because that helps
you to scale up your application without
any hurdle
okay the embedded documents means what
that means the
i would say the parent record as well as
the child records both stores in the
same location
fine so
how exactly that is let's take a look
about this example
here we would like to insert some
records by saying db
dot
student i do not have a student
collection but i'm just telling you
db.student
dot
insert here
we would like to add
some records what i'm trying to say the
registration number
registration number i'm just saying
uh one two three four
you can give anything
now the next one we will talk about
caller name
this name we can say
student one
followed by the next one i'm talking
about which course the student has
registered so we can say
course
inside this course we would like to say
the course name let's say
course name we are giving the course
name called
mca
okay
followed by
another property called duration
okay i am giving this duration
is called
three
years
like that
after that
this curly braces is closing
that means
see
the idea is like you see the course is
an embedded document because from course
you have a few more properties like in
course name and duration
i am closing this and starting the
another
property and that is called address
okay
sorry let me remove from here
and from address and address
we can say one more curly braces
and inside this address we can say city
giving the name called what
bangalore
another one we are using that is called
state
um
let me remove this state
colon
ka
okay and the third property we're using
that is called
country here is saying
ie that is called india
so it is closing here
okay and it is closing here so the inner
document and out document both are
closed
hit enter and now you can see the
records are inserted one thing you might
notice
the course
and the address these two are embedded
documents and they do not have
any
primary key of its own instead the
course and address both are directly
dependent on
the student object
or the student database so
i will say student have the registration
number
fine
and the primary key so the primary key
will be associated with the most outer
document and the inner documents are
directly
associated associated with them and now
when i try to say db dot
student
dot find
you can see now the records are
fetched
i can understand many of you are
thinking every time
while adding the record we do not add
any object id
and here you might have observed and
there also you have option then what
exactly that id is now let me brief you
this id is nothing but a unique primary
key
your mongodb has offered you
that means mongodb says whichever data
you are inserting it
so by default with every single document
mobodb will associate this by default
property called underscore id which you
can't even ignore
however you can override
i haven't provided any
underscore id as a property because this
is a predefined property associated with
every single
mongodb document if you want to override
it you can override
from this value to any value because if
you do not pass any value
this value will be automatically
provided that is a typical hexadecimal
value
however if you want to override it you
can override the value of underscore id
but you can't change the key name
let's try
with some
another record so same record if i try
to add
let's go
i'm using call
student two
and here i'm saying one two three four
five here if i want to override it i can
just say underscore
id
colon now i can give the value call what
1 0 1
this you need to remember so i'm
overriding this value with 1 0 1
now adding it now records are added now
let me call find now you see this time
the records when i fetched
so in this record
the first record contains a default
underscore id in a second record it is
the one which i have provided
and remember one thing in mongodb you
really can't offer any property other
than underscore id as a primary key
here there is no concept of having the
cons
like in composite key which you used to
do
in tradition rdbms here you have only
underscore id and this is the only
property which you can override it else
by default the new value will be given
to you so this is the first way of how
the insert document has been done will
be telling you the another ways where
the other documents are also added
okay so
in the previous examples we have seen
like how we can add the records
but i also tell you there is another
alternative options are available if you
want to insert the records in a bulk
that option is also possible in [ __ ] tv
how we can do let's try to understand
here here we would like to use one very
simple concept for var
my
emp equal to now starting with
a typical
object
like this and after that i mean
adding this
and within this i'm adding the first
property called emp
id
colon 1 after this
okay now you can see it is not
understanding because that is a
challenge when we talk about call
uh
you know
the logical part
because you go with multiple lines it is
not supporting however we have to follow
the same lines now
amp id 1 and we just give the second
property called emp name
so
amp id
just
remove this i just say emp id and i say
amp
name
colon
admin
okay adding it here so
first record here
again i'm adding another one
that is called
emp id
colon2
okay and now
colon
manager
okay again
colon three
and
colon
qa
add it
okay and this curly braces is closing
after this
your square bracket is also closing and
once it is done you come down
and say db
dot
new amp
dot
insert
okay and here you pass the name
of the object called my
afb
and you can see now it is telling you an
inserted tree that is known called bulk
insert when you are inserting multiple
records in a single shot
see how easy it is for you
okay now you simply use
db
dot the collection name is what
your new erp
dot find
and you can see now all three records
are inserted with its default object id
okay so that
is a really nice idea to have
the id to be provided
okay remember this statement so you
understood finally how we can
add the records in a bulk
going forward we will also talk about
which is related to your
update as well as delete in your
upcoming demos okay but here that is the
first thing which you realize it how we
can perform
those kind of operations in very very
simple and straightforward manner okay
everyone so now we have got three
records with us and in case if i am
planning to perform update
on any of my records how will i do this
now so we have a predefined functions
available name called update function
let's see how this update function can
really work so we use this statement
name called db
dot
what is my collection name which is
known as call a new emp new emp
okay
dot
update
okay so
what i will do i will say db dot new emp
dot
update here
okay
now when we talk about call update we
ever
statement available
okay what is that that is called
emp id we were called emp name so we say
wherever the emp id is this i want to
change what the name how can i do this
now
very simple
to perform this what i would like to do
now
i want to basically add few more records
to give you some more better idea
you can see now here we have a call
admin
id name
so
i just do one thing
i just change the ids
uh one two three i just say four
i say five
this is six
okay
and i
call this
again the three records are inserted now
let me try to call find
now we have total number of
six records are available where
admin is repeated manager is repeated qa
is repeated
now let me try to update the record
okay now i want to say db
dot
new emp
dot
update
here
i would like to perform the property
like in what
[Music]
name
as a emp name
amp name
colon
i say admin
okay
so i just close that
and i use
another curly braces with dollar
set that means you want to set the new
value
here we are giving
emp name
okay what i want to do
i say wherever the name is admin change
to what
admin new
that name i want to change it
close this
close this
and run
now you can see it is saying n match to
one
and the record fields are updated like
this let me check
well here i will see
the value called admin new is updated
but i have one more admin called admin
it is not changed and there is something
which you need to notice
what you need to notice is notice is
like when you try to perform update
so what mobo dv does it starts from the
top
find the first record
change the value or modify the value and
come out from the loop
it doesn't carry forward its search
process for the next level of results
and that is something which is
i really want to do that
so in case if you are planning to change
those values
multiple times so what you need to do
let's take a look here in the similar
example here we have a column name admin
second property we will call manager
let's try to say
managers are repeated twice we just want
to change to
new
underscore
manager and i want to update multiple
values so what i will do here
i will put
comma and say
multi
colon
shoot
okay saying multi-color true that you
want to say hey i want to update
multiple
search or multiple repetitions
hit enter this time you can say it is
saying
and match to and modify two that means
two records found and two records are
modified let's check
there we go we have got new manager is
updated in both the location
that's something which is really
awesome because this is how you try to
perform the multiple changes
well in our previous examples you see
like how we can perform the update part
but we have one more beautiful feature
available inside the moho tv and that is
called how exactly we can perform absurd
clear let's talk about absurd upside is
a combinations of update and insert
let me try to show you one magic here
here when we talk about call update part
you see now
here
we are trying to say
uh
this point
yeah you see what multi-tool we have
used
now here
this uh
multi true
is we're trying to update but let's talk
about something called manager2
enter now you can see it is saying no
records formed
clear now no records formed
but there's one concept available in
call absurd absurd means if i try to
perform upset it means if the records
are not available it will insert the
record
i want to show you one simple example
now here we are using multi true
okay
so
as i can see we're using something
called name
and we're performing this update part
so in this update part we are using this
dollar set new manager
so here rather than using multi true
we are saying
absolute true
when i say absurd rule so what happened
now
they say
n matched 0 and up inserted 2 and
modified with id this that means
when i try to call this find function
you will be seeing now we have a got
the another record has been added
are we clear now
as a new record
so absurd does what upset says like if
the records are found
i will update it if it is not i will
insert it
that means if i try to call the same
thing manager 2
fine it is added as a new manager now if
i just try to say
uh
not manager to i will call qa
qa and here we are saying emp equal to
new
underscore qa
and now you can see it is saying n
matched one and upsorted zero and
modified one so it is clearly telling
you like hey i did not find any uh
inserted part but yes i matched one
record i found one record and the one
record is updated now
that is very very beneficial feature
when you really want to perform absurd
so that is the
advantage of that is what's called
update plus insert
very
important feature that depends on the
requirement if you want to add you can
certainly add this
so the way we have tried to add this
up certain part we can also try to
perform the delete part also
okay so momodb
also helps you to perform the delete
part and how you'll be trying to add it
now let's try to understand here in my
code if i want to perform any delete but
i have this statement name called db
dot
the option we are using it that is
called collection name emp
new emp sorry
dot we have option number remove
in this remove we would like to offer
the property
okay and what we're talking about now
here
let's try to add
the id here
or the name which you would like to
import so i want to say like
emp name admin new so we just say
p
name
okay
and then
name score word
admin new
okay emp name admin new when i say
remove
you can see it is record removing the
first record
so you can see now the records are
removed
fine because there is only
one admin new is available
okay now in a similar way if i try to
remove
the property call
new underscore manager
new underscore
management hit enter now you can see the
three records are removed so it's not
like update which removes only one sorry
update only one record
it can also eliminate
more than one records at the same time
that's the benefit of remove so now you
can see we have already implemented some
records
as i seen earlier like we have
performed the delete part now
now when i try to say db
dot
new emp dot find
three records are available with me
three four and six
now
when it comes to c
in third part we have seen update part
we have seen delete part we have seen
now it's time to basically fetch the
records so find function we've already
seen but in find function we also have
some conditions so called queries so in
case if you want to limit the number of
records into your application you can
also do that let's see db
dot
uh
new emp
dot
find
clear now
so in find you can also
pick up the specific records too
like when i'm saying dot find and here
we can just say
name
colon
admin
sorry
here to put curly braces
it says there is no record with the name
called admin
because it is a emp name not a name so
let me change back to
now i can see it finds
one record
so like that you can also apply a
condition
okay enter your code
now
in a similar line if you really don't
want to offer any condition
okay but you want to limit the number of
records to be
shown so you have this function
available name called
limit
to two means only two records now you
can see
though i have three records but it is
only showing me two records because i
have limit
those number of records into my code
also we can perform sorting in case if
you want to perform the sorting in
ascending and descending order that also
you can also do
so here rather than saying limit
we just put this option name called sort
and in this sort on which property you
want to sort it that out you can mention
so we can just say empty name
okay and using ascending order or
descending order so we can just say
minus one let's go descending order
okay
now you can see it is showing the
descending order now if i just say
minus one if you just say one
that is showing you in an ascending
order
so you can pick up the specific property
we have on which
you can tell it should be either on
descending order or ascending order
so that option really works very fine
okay
so that's like how you can perform the
queries but remember one thing you can
also
search
the records based on their embedded
columns too because if you see in a
previous records we have
some records added
okay that is
let me try to say show
collections
i will call
sl student
and student
okay
db
dot
dot
find
okay you can see we have records which
are embedded records
now if you want to search the records
based on their embedded properties like
i'm talking about address this is one
property name called city
fine so if you would like to pick up
those records these are also possible
so how you can do this
very simple so you say tv dot
student
dot
find
okay so inside this file
you can provide the specific properties
like
my outermost property name is called
what address so we are using this option
called
address
dot
dot
city
so we say
city
are we clear colon
i'm giving the city name called what
bangalore
okay let me close this
and that's it
okay
so we have to start passing
another curly braces here hit enter and
you can see now i find two records
because both the records belong to what
[Music]
bangalore so i'm getting this
city bangalore with me
that's really awesome like you can also
pass the city accordingly
a part of that we also have
the other details also
okay in which you can
have the conditions based on less than
greater than or whatever values you
would like to make it
is available and possible
okay so that's how the conditions are
satisfied
so suppose if you would like to pick the
users
i'll be clear
where the range which you would like to
consider so those are also possible like
you can see we have this property name
called what emp id 3 and 6
i just want to pick up only those
records whose id is greater than
what 2 so what i can say
db
dot
new emp
okay
dot
find
and inside this file we can say
the property
okay so what's property we're using emp
id we're saying
emp id here
colon here we'll be using
dollar
gt
gc stands for what greater than colon
we're giving the value call what one
right
close this
run you can see you have received three
records three four and six
in case if i just look forward for
higher than five
you will see only one record so greater
than that's called gt
okay
same option if i just say lt
you can see we have found
two records so less than greater than
okay so that's how exactly you offer it
okay and also you can provide the
condition so-called limit as i can say
find emp id the way we provide it so
here i will not use
less than
okay
instead i'll be providing another
property let me show you what
so here in emp id whatever we have taken
so let me
try to take the property call file and
here we are providing emp
id
and then
and we're using other curly braces and
we're using dollar in
is very important property dollar in
colon here you provide the details
i'm saying
uh inside so the property is three four
six we are saying
three
comma
six
close this
and you can see we got two records
which matched with three and six that's
the benefit of having
this
okay everyone so in our previous example
we have already seen lot many activities
this time we are trying to offer you
something very interesting feature and
that is known as called working with
indexing see mongodb is one of the most
popular tool
and one of the reason why it is very
popular because it is having the
facility of having indexing now what
exactly the index does so friends main
job of having this index is to basically
give you the concept of like how
one particular
document which is huge document
in case if you would like to perform any
sort of indexing inside this how you
will be applying this
so to apply indexing into my code
let's
try to understand why index is really
required without indexing
and with indexing how you'll be making a
difference into the code
so to make it happen we would like to
insert some records
to confirm
okay
so what i will do is in step number one
previous records if i see i have got
four six three four one depends on
what early records we had it
so we had to call
new emp
so db dot
new emp
dot
find we have total number of three
records are available so it's okay we
can have this three requires with me
now
let me try to apply indexing
without indexing if i want to find a
result what outcome i'm gonna receive so
to know about
how much time it gonna be taking if if i
have a got large number of records with
me
i'll be using this statement name called
db
dot the name is called new emp
dot
explain
and here i will be using one predefined
functionality called
execution stats
execution starts
okay
now here after the execution starts will
be using dot
fine
we'll be using the first property here
okay
and
what user would like to find it that you
need to basically offer it so we are
giving the name called emp name
colon
giving the name call
qa
okay let's close
okay
now when i press hit enter execution
stats is a predefined
functionalities which will tell me
when the query was executed what exactly
the query plan was hit enter and now you
can see
a lot of details
are available with me
like you can see
pass query winning plan and everything
one thing you need to remember by
default
here when i try to run
it says and return one
advance one need time
total everything it is showing me
but one important thing which you will
see here
is
total number of documents is scanned
so it is telling me total number of
document examined is three
clear now
and return one that means one result is
returned and the total number of
documents examines three in order to
find this record
just imagine a use case here
where i say total number of documents
examine three in case if i ever got
millions of records with me
that means to search the record it will
examine all the millions number of
records to search the result which
certainly gonna be taking huge amount of
time
and that's where exactly when you try to
search the record
fine when you
have no indexing is available
okay so you need to understand one
important thing is
by default index is applied on your
underscore id db
dot
new emp
um
yeah db.dmp dot
when i say db.new emp dot get index is a
predefined function it tells me like hey
by default index is applied or
underscore id
that's the
fact because by default
index is applied on underscore id not on
the other properties
so i need to identify
which are the properties are required to
be get indexes
mongodb advantages it is supporting
multi-column indexes
and that's what exactly we would like to
see
so let's see in our next demo
now we will try to apply indexing on our
own property
okay so to apply the index what we need
to do we have to say db
dot
certainly we will be talking about call
collection name call
new emp
dot
create
index
here you have to pass
two things number one
on which property would like to apply
okay and it has to be ascending or
descending
so i'm trying to apply on
emp
name
and i want the index to be applied on
ascending order
okay so here
colon one
hit enter you can see now
it is telling me
like uh number of indexes before one and
number of indexes after two that means
earlier index was available only on one
particular property now it is apply on
two properties
if you want you can check
now you can see there's another
properties added called emp underscore
now if i try to execute a similar query
which i executed earlier
qa
now you'll be seeing there's a different
statistics all together
here
if i see
in my code
see it will tell you total document
examined one
see now earlier the number of document
examined were three but since this index
is applied not notice telling me the
total number of document examined is one
so performance is certainly improved
so to search your document it won't be
searching the complete
collections
okay rather it will search what
only
that particular column in which it is
actually applied for
so that's the benefit in fact i would
say when you will be using these kind of
indexes
into your code okay
so hope we all are clear and understood
about this concept so let's go ahead and
get this implemented into our system
well this is the first way of how the
index can be applied so you can also
apply index on multiple properties
clear so that we will show you one by
one how it is
okay everybody so we have already seen
in our previous example how we have
applied
indexes in our existing mongodb
application
so
it is also a possibilities where we want
to also apply the index on other number
of properties too as you can see in our
existing database
okay an existing collection my
collection name is new emp which
contains
two different properties one is called
emp id and second called emp name
just now we have applied index on our
emp name but in case if i want to apply
index on emp id i'll be using the same
technique okay let's try to apply index
on the same
so first of all get indexes i'm having
this index applied on two different
property now we would like to say db
dot
create
index
and here in this db dot create index we
can just
i will say db.collection name so our
collection name is called new emp new
amp
dot create index
first parameter is certainly the name of
which property we are applying so here
is saying emp id
and in this amp id we will just offer it
has to be ascending or descending let me
decide descending order
so we are saying
minus one
okay
now let's
press enter and check the status
okay now you can see earlier indexes
which we have created that was two and
now it turns to three so it is very
clear that index is improving now let's
check this out
uh db dot
new mp.get indexes now we have a total
number of three indexes are available
so you can apply index or
n number of columns if you want
okay at the same time
the way we have created the index in
case if i want to drop an index
so we can also drop so what we can do db
dot new emp
dot
drop index
drop
index
and in this drop index we have to
provide
which particular index we would like to
draw
remember this point in case if you're
planning to drop any sort of index so
you need to provide which index so you
should have that particular index name
okay so here
we are providing my index name so it
should not be uh i would say the
traditional name called emp id no it has
to be emp id
underscore minus one or
emp name underscore one so this should
be the name i'm saying emp
name in case if you try this
you see it is saying index not found
with the emp name because internally it
maintains with this name
let's try this out we say emp
name
underscore one let's try
and now you can see new index was three
okay one
okay
now you can see we have a call emp id
and underscore id
so
now we have
only two indexes left
there's no emp name anymore this is how
exactly you can drop the indexes
so it is very simple and straightforward
way of how
in mongodb you can perform your
activities hello everybody and welcome
back
in a previous examples of mobodb you
might have considered
we have used lot many operations in our
last video we have seen
how to utilize
indexing into our code now in our next
journey of our mongodb we will see how
aggregation works see in mobile db
aggregation plays a vital role and
aggregation comes with so many handy
functions with mongodb which will help
you to perform
and to apply
some very simple code snippets into your
ongoing
uh i would say the requirement which can
make your query so much seamless now we
will see how this aggregation really
works and to work on an aggregation we
have taken some default database name
called aggregate db and here we have a
call student as a by default collection
in which we have some set of
records are already added
now
if i just want to apply aggregation now
i would like to tell you about what
exactly the aggregation is
see ideally when you talk about call
aggregation okay so aggregation is
nothing but a call aggregate like rdbms
if you see mythical aggregation there so
the unix command like you talk about
shell pipeline means the possibility to
execute an operation on some input and
use that output as an input for the next
command
that means the output of one particular
execution becomes an input for others
so mongodb also supports same kind of
concept in aggregation framework there's
so many type of
functionalities are available which we
will see one by one
into our next code
okay now here we want to confirm about a
few important things
now here let me try to bring some of the
important
well-known
i would say the functionalities of our
aggregation framework first we use the
term name called dollar project
the project
is basically designed for
select
a specific
specific fields
dollar project is designed to select
what specific fields from a collection
we used to talk about call what
dollar match
the match is responsible
to filter out the operations
are we clear now it is designed to
filtering out the operations
you talk about dollar group
talk about dollar group so it
does the actual aggregation
fine we talk about call dollar
sort